[Musique]
une sorte de révolution vient de
s'opérer celle du moteur individuel le
pi cyclo motorisé est devenu le roi des
transports urbains
signe des temps les transports en commun
se plaignent de voir diminuer nos
recettes bien sûr un peu plus chaque
jour il semble que leur passage et les
déserte pour des engins qui donne la
faculté du porte à porte et le
témoignage de l'indépendance
il n'a pas son vélomoteur depuis le
porteur de journaux qui s'est lassé de
pédaler jusqu'à la femme pressée qui
fait son marché entre ces heures de
travail
[Musique]
on camillo roule en moto et c'est sur
une vespa que les jeunes mariés font
leurs premiers pas dans la vie
ange à pratiquer qui se faufilent qui
passe par dix en jeu dangereux qui vont
trop vite qui gêne les autres qui
départagera partisans et contradicteurs
le cyclomoteur est une revanche celle du
paria de la rue d'hier qui traite
aujourd'hui de faire avec toutes les
cylindrées comme elle il est autonome
comme elle ils possèdent sont l'évasion
en puissance c'est un moteur
[Musique]